all right let's get to a few more things
um it's been a very very strange 24
hours for the former president Donald
Trump while Joe Biden prepares to
address the nation tomorrow about
coronavirus and to lay out uh a
six-pronged strategy for how we are
going to get Beyond this thing Donald
Trump is going to be doing pay-per-view
commentary of some kind for a boxing
match former president Donald Trump and
also appeared on Newsmax last night and
lied completely uncontrollably just
totally uncontrollably about
um everything I want to start with this
first clip Donald Trump was asked about
the California gubernatorial election
which we will be talking about in the
next segment we are going to be covering
the results live next week this is an
important situation in California Donald
Trump claimed of course without any
evidence that it's probably rigged this
is happening in the context of Gavin
Newsom starting to pull away in terms of
people saying we want to keep Newsome
instead of we call him in the polling
we'll get to that polling in a moment
here is Donald Trump just spreading lies
it wasn't a joke when we said they will
just start claiming any election they
lose was rigged that's exactly what
Donald Trump is doing here take a look
at this got the recall election coming
up in less than a week it's actually
happening as we speak the polls appear
to show Newsom looks safer at this point
Larry Elder is the man that could take
it from him what do you think happens in
California well it's probably rigged
they're sending out all ballots it's all
uh the the ballots are you know mail out
mail-in ballots in fact I guess you even
have a case where you can make your own
ballot when that happens uh nobody's
going to win except these Democrats so
you know look they're they're very good
the one thing they're good at is rigging
elections so I predict it's a rigged
election let's see how it so what's
going on in reality is simply that Gavin
Newsom is pulling away it was very very
close about a month ago in early August
list basically split awareness was much
lower about the fact that this was going
on at the time among Californians and as
we and others I mean I'm not I'm not
saying we accomplished anything but just
as there's been more and more attention
by media about the fact that hey you
could see Newsome removed despite the
amazing economy in California and
replaced with a lunatic Like Larry Elder
you've started to see the keep Newsome
crowd uh pull away where now they are
almost plus 10 plus 10. now everybody's
got a vote in California my brother said
he uh uh was was filling out his ballot
today it's got to be post postmarked by
uh actually I hope that it's I hope I'm
right about it I think it has to be
postmarked by Tuesday
um so hopefully that'll happen but there
is no evidence whatsoever that that this
is rigged it wasn't a joke when we said
this is the new story
anytime they lose they'll say it was
rigged Mitt Romney who won in Utah
remember that confrontation I believe it
was at um national airport in Washington
DC where a woman came up to him and said
you didn't really win that your win was
also rigged any win they don't like they
simply say was rigged and what's going
on unfortunately is that this is the
type of stuff that could lead to what
we're worried will happen on September
18th which is another one of these
um riots I mean I I hope it doesn't go
that way Trump continuing to lie
throughout the interview then he
repeated his often cited uh lie that he
was down there at Ground Zero on 9 11
we're coming up on the 20th anniversary
of 9 11 and here's Donald Trump
revisiting that same lie at that time
you you offered to help
um oh yeah what a mess we had in New
York City give us your reflection of
that period of time 20 years later
Imagine by the way asking Trump to
reflect that's that's that alone is
funny well I was down there right after
the event and I brought a big crew of
people down and I helped a lot of other
people help those First Responders are
very brave and I'm telling you that's a
lie Trump has been telling that lie a
really really long time back in 2019 you
might remember Trump commemorated 9 9 11
First Responders by making it all about
himself he is told this lie many many
times here is Trump in 2019 telling
something very similar untrue it also
provides pensions for those who are
suffering from cancer and other
illnesses stemming from the toxic debris
they were exposed to in the aftermath of
the attacks many of those affected were
firefighters police officers and other
First Responders and I was down there
also but I'm not considering myself a
first responder but I was down there I
spent a lot of time down there with you
so there there appears to be absolutely
no evidence of that Snopes looked into
it and
um he uh claimed that he was there uh
doing who knows what but Snopes spoke to
officials from New York City Fire
Department they spoke to the
construction demolition people who were
at Ground Zero for days and days and
days after the 9 11 attacks nobody
recalls ever seeing Trump down there and
Trump has been exaggerating
um about it for a very very long time so
that's what's going on and then even
weirder as if it needs to get any
weirder Donald Trump is going to be
providing boxing commentary
for uh triller's Evander Holyfield veter
Belfort fight on the 20th anniversary of
9 11 just like everything is so bizarre
it's weird enough
that Trump as a former president is
doing boxing commentary it's kind of
even weirder in some strange way that
he's doing it on the 20th anniversary of
9 11. just all of it reeks of bizarre
confusion and uh I don't ultimately know
what Trump's political future is but so
far it's all looking very strange if you
ever feel like you just don't have
enough time to read all the books you
want to read you have to check out one
of my favorite apps called blinkist
blinkist takes thousands of popular
non-fiction books and distills each one
down into an e-book or audiobook that
you can get through in just 15 minutes
where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book just imagine how
you'll be able to expand your horizons
and knowledge by being able to soak up
all of the important insights from 10
different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for or you can use it
to revisit a book you've already read or
use it to preview a book before you buy
the full version and read it I recently
read A Brief History of Time Of course
by the great Stephen Hawking this is a
book that I have been aware of for so
long and other things got in the way and
it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com Pacman I've put the link
right underneath this video